c'est devenu un rituel cette saison à
grenon la communion des joueurs du tvb
avec leur public voyait ces images
c'était hier soir les tourangeaux
qualifié pour la finale de la coupe ceb
cinq ans après leur dernier titre de
champion d'europe défaits à l'aller par
les polonais de belchatow les joueurs de
marcello fronckowiak ont renversé la
vapeur pour l'emporter 3 7 1 le résumé
de la rencontre avec audrey champigny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 2-2
[Musique]
aussi on apprend pape les sports la joie
la hargne l'envi que d'émotions nous ont
offert les joueurs du tvb hier soir
après de s'être emporté tout en maîtrise
25 21 25 20 les tourangeaux plonge dans
le dur dans la troisième manche malgré
les coups de patte de corric les
polonais reprennent du poil de la bête
et s'impose 21 25 mais c'est sans
compter sur le septième homme de cette
soirée le public chauffé à bloc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai ensuite mais je trouve une ambiance
exceptionnelle c'est un vrai bonheur et
l'absence de tilly savait pas trop
remarqué c'est superbe et on line et on
a vraiment des très bons très bons
éléments ce soir ils seront très forts
je connais très bien la pologne
la malbaie tchato mais ça va être pour
entrer chez eux je pense très très vite
et effectivement le patron hier soir
c'était bien tour une remontée d'un
magistral dans le quatrième set un
service raté de nicole pour la balle de
match et le tvb s'envole en finale
direction l'italie notre bout de cet été
n'avait service et je est un autre jour
vu la dream team qu'on a c'est pas
surprenant je suis pas surpris le
collectif le staff tout l'ensemble ne
fait qu'un et je peux vous le dire
puisque voilà une grosse solidarité on
va y aller pour
le rappeur avis donc aux milanais logo
tourangeau a faim rendez vous le 16 mars
pour le match aller en italie et le 23 à
gronau pour le match retour